Merhaba bugün benim için gerçekten çok
önemli ve çok güzel bir gün her şeyden
önce hayatımın ilk TED konuşmasını
izlediğimde Koç lisesindeyim yani tomura
olmayabilirim O sırada ama orada
okuyordum ve o zamanlar üniversite
hazırlıklarını yapmak istiyorsun kendini
tanımak istiyorsun hayata dair Benim
hayata dair kitaplar dışında açıp da
Öğrenebildin hissettiğim ilk Eee teddi
Benim için o yüzden bu an benim için çok
anlamlı daha o zamanlar herhangi adıma
dair herhangi bir girişim veya bir Eee
kendime dair Duygu gurur duyduğum bir
durum olmasa dahi o günlerde ilk Tedi
izlediğim anda nedense bu da neden
olmasına bir işaret oluyor burada bir
konuşma
zaten burada bir bakalım şimdi şey
yapacağız burada bir konuşma yapmak
isterim diye kendi içimden geçirmiştim o
zamanlar nasıl olur ne olur açıkçası tam
olarak bilmesem de bugün E şu an çok
anlamlı bir gün sabah da Koç
üniversitesi'de diim O yüzden tam döngü
anı diyebiliriz öncesinde üniversiteden
sonra şimdi de lisede beni besleyen
Aslında Ailemden sonra Bendeki etkileri
ve izlerini çok net
görebileceğimiz iki ana kaynağın
içerisinden Bugün sizlerle birlikte
geçiyorum merak edenler olabilir Eee
Öncelikle dukea başlamıştım Daha
sonrasında Koç Üniversitesi'nde devam
ettim ve üniversiteyi tamamladım kısaca
açıklamam gerekirse tek yapmak istediğim
benim kendimi adayabilir olarak ait
hissedebileceğim bir yerde olmaktı
Amerika'ya ilk giderken yine kendimi çok
istediğim için gittim kimse beni
zorlamadı burada kalmam çok daha herkes
için daha uygundu ama Amerika'ya
giderken de özgür olmak bir şeyleri
yırtmak geçmek ve kendime ait düzeninin
sahibi olmak için gittim Amerika'da bu
ihtiyacımı üniversite ortamında
tamamlayamadığı hissettiğim için de
aslında okumaktan bağımsız bir yaşama
sahip olmak ve bir yaşamın yaratıcısı
olmak için İstanbul'a geri döndüm o
sırada Koç Üniversitesi e mükemmel bir
yer gibi gözüktü bana Hem yeşilliğin
ortasında hem biliyorum ki eğitim
olabildiğince iyi Dolayısıyla oraya
yatay geçiş yaptım ve bir sürü ders
Aslında sayılmadan tekrardan sanki
üniversiteye başlıyormuş gibi oldum 2
sene liberal dua felsefe ekonomi
Fransızca okuduktan sonra Koç
Üniversitesindeki hayatım Gerçekten
çok okul odaklı olmasına rağmen bana
kattığı her şey okuldan çok daha
öte bu çok kısaca mezuniyetime artık
gelirsek mezuniyetim sırasında inanın ne
yapacağımı bilmiyordum hayata dair
kendime dair her şeyden önce aydınlanmak
isteyen bir insan
olarak yaşamın içerisinde var olmaya
çalışıyorsun insanlarla konuşmaya
çalışıyorsun kendini ifade etmeye
çalışıyorsun ve Belki bir yandan da bazı
içinde sakladığın bu kendi konuşmaların
seni
uzaklaştırabilir rektörümüz Ümran Hoca
Kendisi çok akıllı bir hareket yaparak
Zeynep Aycan'a yönlendirdi Bugün de onun
yanından geliyorum Zeynep Aycan Koç
üniversitesi'de profesörümüz TÜBİTAK
ödüllü çok nadir ülkemizde de
hanımefendi profesörlerden bilim
kadınlarından bilim adamlarından şimdi
bu neden önemli Çünkü az önce söylediğim
bu aydınlanmak kelimesini üniversitede
veya herhangi bir yerde söylediğimde
bana çok normal bir şekilde karşılayan
ve beni gerçekten hayata dair
yönlendirmek için doğru hareketi yapan
ve bu Tabii ki yetkinliğe sahip olan
hocaydı
Dolayısıyla şunu söylemek istiyorum ne
istediğiniz Bazen çok garip geliyor
olabilir
Eee Gerçekten ne istediğimizi kendi
içimizde tanımladıktan sonra dürüst
olabileceğimiz bazı atılımlar yapmak ve
bazı sorulara da Doğru cevaplar vermek
durumundayız Zeynep hocamın Koç
Üniversitesi'nden sonra eee beni o
sırada Koç Üniversitesi sosyal etki
forumunda çalışmaya yönlendirme iyle
birlikte 2 senelik bir deneyim
sonrasında kendi girişimi kuracak
özgüvene sahip oldum yani bunun
öncesinde üniversite sırasında veya lise
sırasında iş yapmaya dair herhangi bir
istek veya Yürek içerisinde içinde
bulunmazken üniversite yıllarından sonra
özellikle girişimcilik alanında zaten
var halihazırda olan çalışmaları
Gördükten ve sosyal etki adı altında
iyilik adı altında yapmaya
çalıştıklarımız nasıl ul ğından ve
nereye vardığını veya varmadığı tespit
ettikten sonra ben de hayatın içerisinde
hareket etmek istedim Bu sırada 19
yaşımdan itibaren çok fazla sayıda tü
dostumu sahiplendim Evim küçük bir
barınak merkezine dönüştü geçici yuva
kalıcı yuva bir sürü Dostumla birlikte
yaşadık ve bu sırada onların hayatını
hakkında ve psikolojilerine dair çok
fazla şey öğrenme fırsatım oldu hayatım
gerçek anlamda tüylü Dostlarım
mutlu olmak onlarla huzur içerisinde
yaşamak odağında gelişmeye başladı Hatta
başka bir seferde hatırlıyorum Yine
benzer daha bu kadar Formal olmayan bir
ortamda üniversiteye yeni başlayacak
öğrencilerle konuştuğumuzda E bu benim
sadece kedi ve köpeklerle olan
düşkünlüğüm ona biraz garip gelmişti ne
yapmak istiyorsun 5 sene sonra kendini
Nerede görüyorsun diye bana
sorduklarında henüz o sırada kafamda bir
şey olamadığım
için bence onları da biraz yıldırmış daı
öyle hissetmiştim Yani bir belirsizlik
Dünyası O yüzden şunu söylemek istiyorum
net olmadığımız anlar olabilir her an
sonsuza kadar o anda çok net
olmayabiliriz ama netlik var ve netliğe
ulaşabiliyoruz o anda net değilseniz Eee
netmiş gibi davranmaya gerek yok Sonra
Çünkü girdiğimiz rolden çıkmak bence çok
daha zor oluyor bu anlamda dürüstlük
gerçekten çok önemli bir ilke Kendimize
karşı dürüst olduğumuzda hayatımız da
bize en güzel bizi bildiği şekliyle ve
bizi mutlu edecek şekilde gelmeye
başlıyor Ama bu dürüstlüğe ulaşabilmemiz
için işte önce hem kendimize sorular Hem
de hayat içerisindeki bu soyulmaları
yaşamamız gerekiyor bize ait olmayan Eee
yargıları bize ait olmayan öğretileri
Bizim kendi
hakkımızda düşündüğümüz ama aslında
bizim yaratmadığı düşünceleri tek tek
tek tek tek bırakmak gerekiyor
kendimizle dair yarattığımız O görüntüyü
Tekrar baştan çizmek gerekiyor gerekirse
kağıt kalemle de bunu yapabilirsiniz
Bence mükemmel bir egzersiz kim
olduğunuzu çizebilirsiniz yanına neyi
temsil ettiğinizi yazabilirsiniz ve neyi
temsil etmediğinizi ve neyi görmek
istemediğinizi yazabilirsiniz Bunlar
benim kendi kendime uyguladığım bazı Eee
kendimle dürüst olma çalışmaları ve
tekrardan seçme tekrardan yeniden kim
olduğuna karar verme çalışmaları kim
olduğumuza her an yeniden karar
verebiliriz ve vermeliyiz Çünkü bugünün
getirdiği yeniliklere
zorluklara ve güçlüklere dünün
kişisi
erişemeyeceği Geride bıraktığımız kişi
Eee çok daha güzel bir şekilde devam
ediyor ve aslında bunları da tam olarak
söylerken Hani hep düşündüğümde
pişmanlık Eee çok şükür hiç başıma
gelmedi ama pişmanlığa en yakın şey
sadece Belki şu Olabilir sizlerin
yaşında kendimi yü bir milyon daha fazla
Severdim Yani eskiden dünyaya insanlara
kendimi tanımak için baktığımı
hatırlıyorum ama ne zaman ki kendimi
tanıtmak için kendime bakmaya
başladığımda O zaman çok daha net
yorulmadığım yorulsam da yorulmama deyen
ve daha fazla mükafatı olan bir yola
girmiş oldum şim burada çok kısaca
göstermek yorum sizi işle ilgili bir
Atılım yaptıktan sonra 2018'de
Türkiye'de ilk defa özgün bir markayla
evcil hayvanlar için çiğ hayvan maması
yem üretmeye başladık ve Türkiye'de ilk
defa kullanılmayan bir
teknolojiyle Aslında yanımıza taşıması
zor olan ham çiğ besinleri hiçbir
şekilde proteinlere veya vitaminlerine
mineraller zarar vermeden onları elimine
etmeden ve koruyarak yanımızda
taşınabilecek bir free drying
teknolojisini ilk defa Türkiye'de tüylü
dostlarımız için kullanmaya başladık
daha önceden bebekler veya çocuk
besinleri için de kullanılmaya
başlanmıştı Ama bu endüstride ilk defa
oldu burada bir garaj hikayesi olduğu
için özellikle bu resmi paylaşmak
istiyorum
2017-2018 sonunda Zekeriya Köy'de
olabilen en uygun kirayla bu yeri
bulduktan
sonrasında gerçekten çok olağanüstü bir
ekip işi zamanlama ve adanmışlık sonra
bugün geldiğimiz nokta burası
Kocaeli'nde gerçekten olağanüstü
derecede büyük bir operasyon
içerisindeyiz yurt dışına Eee satmak
kelimesi bile değil yurt dışına
eriştirmek ürünlerin her yerde olması
bütün dünyada var olması benim için
neden olmasın tam olarak bu yani çünkü
gerçekten yarattıklarımızın
eğitimlerle sahip olduğum hem Eee
gerçekten hani gönül zenginliğiyle hem
dostluklarım Yapabileceğim her şeyi göze
alarak yorucu bir hayat olmasına rağmen
neden olmasın sorusuyla her gün yanın
devam etmeye özen gösteriyorum çünkü
Eğer ne için yorulacağız seçmezsek başka
binlerce şey için yorulabiliyor o yüzden
her zaman ne için yorulacağız kendimiz
seçersek inanın daha az yoruluyoruz
Burada sadece birkaç tane kitap önerisi
yapmak istedim fotoğrafını çekmek
isteyen dostlarım için bunlar olağanüstü
derecede herhangi bir dnr veya kitapçı
da belki hemen karşımıza çıkm ama
hayatımızı dönüştürecek sadece
iş bağımsız benim bu şu anda bahsettiğim
her şey kişisel iş de benim için kişisel
aile de benim için kişisel Çünkü tek bir
kişi yaşıyor o yüzden bu kişiyi ne kadar
iyileştirip
besleyebilirsiniz
bahsetmiştim yeni nesil liderlik şu an
liderlik konusunda yazılan en güncel
kitap gerçekten kültürümüze uyumluluk
dahilinde verdiği önerileri yaptığı
teşhisleri okurken her sayfasında
aydınlanıyor biz de bir Kitap Kulübü
kuruyoruz kendi ofisimizde O yüzden
Sizlerin de ilgi göstermesini rica
ediyorum çok beğeneceksiniz çok kısaca
bahsediyorum yine Dr Nick çiğ besleyen
veteriner topluluğu kurucusu başkanı 35
yıldır bu işi yapıyor benim 4 yıldır 5
yıldır yaptığım işi 35 yıldır yapıyor
ve
gerçekten benim bir gün kardeşimi
ziyarette üniversitede İngiltere'de
okurken drck de İngiltere'de yaşıyor
burada londralı olmamasına rağmen ona
hemen bir yazayım dememle uçaktan
indiğim saniyede emilime cevap
gelmesiyle ilk ilişkimiz başladı ve
şimdi o 3 sene sonrasında birkaç ay
öncesinde İstanbul'da beraberdik seminer
verdik Ve bu gelişmeye devam ediyor
Bunları özellikle gösteriyorum Çünkü
uygulamada da her
şeyin kadar güzel ve istediğiniz gibi
olabileceğini söylemek istiyorum Benim
için çok önemli iki karakter Steve Jobs
ve wily Wonka imgeler benim için çok
önemli bu sebeple yani Yaptığım işleri
de bu boyutta hem vizyoner hem de
olabildiğince hem çılgın hem de
gerçekten yaratıcılık yaratıcılık
özelliğinde geliştirerek devam etmek
istiyorum Benim de kendime niyetim bu
ama bütün bu konuşmaları izlediğimde Tüü
dostlarımdan ilhamla şimdi bu renklerle
bu
güzelliklerle mutluluğu içerisinde Benim
aktarabileceğimiz
de buluşturduğu için çok teşekkür
ediyorum bugün dinlediğim bütün
konuşmalar için çok teşekkür ediyorum
kulağımızın kiri pası gitti Selen Hanım
için özel bir konser Çok teşekkür
ediyorum Bunlar benim gerçekten
[Müzik]
özetleyebiliriz ekran görüntüsü
alabilirsiniz Eğer ki E bir şeyi
gerçekten istiyorsak ve bu bizim için
hayırlıysa bu
olacaktır bunda bir şüphe etmeye gerek
yok çünkü içimizde Doğan istekler zaten
kendimizde var olan bir yolun işaretleri
gitmek istediğimiz yolun işaretleri
varmak istediğimiz kişinin işaretleri
Ama bu demek değil ki dün yanlıştık
bugün doğruyuz öyle bir şey değil benim
onu anlayana kadar çok uzun vaktim geçti
o yüzden hiçbir şeyin hata olmadan
tamamen mükemmel bir öğrenim yolu
olduğunu bilerek Neden olmasın demeye
devam ediyoruz beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür
[Alkış]
ederim